[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's going on youtube hey it's
cameron with motion science i am so glad
to have you guys here with me today
uh how's everyone doing on this fine day
let me know who's here today
uh what's going on in your part of the
world
uh
okay here let's get started um today
we're talking about
three simple methods to improve your
designs
three simple methods to improve your
designs uh but before i get into that i
do wanna hear from you guys um i love
hearing from you guys
so i want to know
what do you struggle with
the most when it comes to designing
can you design can you not design
and that's okay too
do you struggle with type do you
struggle with color compositions
elements
overall as i mentioned composition you
know what what do you struggle with like
getting the idea out there if there's an
idea in your head that you're kind of
stuck on and you can't translate it to
the screen
i want to know from you what do you
struggle with with design because um you
know design is super important
in motion design i like to emphasize the
word design italicize the word design
there's we are motion designers
italicized right and so many of us know
how to animate
and
do that kind of thing set keyframes and
move things and all that but a lot of us
or many of us don't know how to design
and it's super important that we
understand design because
even if you're animating you're moving
elements across the screen you need to
understand composition and things like
that so that when you're moving things
that it still looks
pleasing to the eye
for those of you who don't know why who
i am my name is cameron i've been a
motion designer for 20 years
a lot of experience in after effects
system of 4d
i taught myself design an animation
many years ago i built reals out of spec
work and i've create that i've created
for myself and that's how i landed my
first
design jobs
i was remote for the answer for 13 years
i've owned and operated two
studios and i've had the opportunity to
work with a lot of big name clients
studios agencies
and things like that
that i've really enjoyed working with so
i've had a lot of experience
as a full-time employee as a freelancer
and as a studio owner
so we've got some comments coming in
here
uh what's up zack
jw what's going on
daniel
raphael what's up from brazil awesome gp
what's going on gp
anda
devicks
mr m2
hello mr m2
vj
luke starkiller
has issues getting started okay getting
started so maybe like
getting
so maybe have an idea and it's like okay
where do i go with this idea
how do i get it on the screen that's a
really challenging thing for a lot of
people
uh here we go one how can i analyze
already done intro style frames i always
find something inspiring i have no idea
how to start
doing it watch the three-part videos
about style frames yeah so you know
essentially
it's just a matter of
building out a little creative brief for
yourself
and like if you study an example you
build a simple creative brief
you constrain yourself to using a set of
colors a set of assets
designs whatever it is you can strain
yourself you give yourself creative
constraints
and then
you start building and you rough in
designs
and
then you kind of polish designs you kind
of go from there
but a lot of people get stuck when
you're starting i get it that's that's a
common thing as well
it's just a matter also of just taking a
step forward one little step
at a time
making your way down the path and
eventually you'll get there
but the first thing is to get that
creative brief i'm a huge believer in
creating creative briefs for ourself uh
so that we can give ourselves parameters
to work within
and constraints because if the world if
your palette is just wide open you're
never going to start right you're always
going to be like overwhelmed because you
could try everything you could do
everything so where do you even begin
right but if you limit
what you're working with and you limit
that down it's much easier to get
started
what's up dan 550 what's up
um steven currently struggling with
motivation
yeah i mean if you're not if
if you're having to push it and it's not
coming naturally to you then you know
look at some other things in your life
what uh what are you resisting uh
sometimes i mean we all get go through
it
so
you know
if it's not the right i mean it's still
like i don't believe in forcing things
if you're having a challenging time
moving forward
maybe just taking some time for yourself
and taking a break maybe you have
burnout i don't know
um
and just having a you know just
working on a little thing at a time
jw i find asset collection the slowest
part of the process but i find that in
other design fields also your suggestion
of envato has been helpful awesome
uh hey cameron great to see you again
took one of the motion science courses
loved it i hope all as well awesome
aaron thank you steven
hands awesome prayer uh so speaking of
design that's what we're talking about
today but i have a new challenge coming
up centered around style frame design uh
in a few weeks so i did a challenge
about uh starting a career in motion
design a few weeks ago
and it was awesome and i got a lot of
awesome results from people out of it so
i have a new challenge coming up and
it's actually four weeks away but i just
opened up registration today
uh to let people know about it earlier
this time so it's four weeks out
um
it is a challenge it's a five day
challenge it's called
the motion design challenge how to
easily concept and design style frames
without prior knowledge
like i said it's five days long it's
live teaching it's q and a's with me
it's all live if you can't watch it live
it is recorded every day so you can go
back and watch it
but if you want to understand how to
create style frames then you need to
check out this challenge
i have a little screen here it is motion
science dot tv
slash
challenge
motion science dot tv slash challenge
that is the only way you're gonna see it
so you have to register for the
challenge it's not gonna be up here on
youtube
to watch you have to register for it and
i want to get as many people in this
challenge as possible
it's five days long as i said and i will
teach you how to design style frames
easily
concept design polish all that jazz
okay
so let's talk about designing in motion
design
and as i mentioned i just want to show
three simple ways
that we can
make our compositions
look better that is key to making you
know we have to understand design rules
so that we can make our compositions
look better so i'm going to switch over
here
and let's actually look at this image
first and
the three things we're going to talk
about
we're going to start with the rule of
thirds okay so this pretty simple
example here is just i've got an image
here just a still image and this could
be video footage it doesn't matter right
just for this example i just want to
show you what i'm talking about here so
there's this there's this design rule
that says if we use the rule of thirds
we can make our compositions much look
much more pleasing to our eye
versus not using it and this is
something that i struggled with for a
long time when i was
new to motion design like i didn't
understand you know what it meant to
actually design i just kind of guessed
at things and sometimes things would
look good
sometimes they wouldn't
um
it was a crap shoot okay but once i
discovered what the rule of thirds is
uh it changed my design game
forever
so
what this is is is we're dividing our
screen up into blocks three blocks
across three blocks down and it doesn't
matter what size our composition is this
works across the board and an easy way
to do this in after effects
is actually to go to your preferences
and
go down to
grids and guides now i'm using after
effects 2020 still
this works in any version of after
effects so your menu your preference
menu may be slightly different but grids
and guides is where it's at
and by default
the horizontal and the vertical
is not going to be three by three it may
be something like you know nine by six
or
something it's probably not gonna be
three by three but what i do is i set my
preferences to three by three and then
moving forward every project file that i
work with within after effects is three
by three
so once i have that set up i click okay
and again
these menu items down here have slightly
changed in the newer versions of after
effects
i'm on 2020 because i don't believe in
using the newest version of after
effects because they're typically bugs
so i could be using 2021
i just love 2020 so far so
i'm gonna go to
proportional grid and when i click that
on you can see i've got my three boxes
across
and my three boxes down because this is
the rule of thirds
and what the rule of thirds tells me is
that
what is most pleasing to my eye is this
spot right here right the second most
pleasing spot on the composition is
right here
the third is right here and the fourth
is right here
now
those are just hot spots for
your screen of where elements can rest
but it also tells me that i should look
at these horizontal lines here and here
and these vertical lines here and here
now you can see this box here in the
middle like this is a center point maybe
for text maybe that works there but what
i'm going to do here is i am going to
look at aligning this image first let's
turn off our type and let's just hit s
for scale
and let's bring down our the size of our
image
maybe in here
and then if i
was holding down shift here
if i make the majority
of my image rest in this
section down here this lower third
that's already much more pleasing to my
eye right now maybe i could drop it down
in here
it's challenging because we have
background trees and we have foreground
trees right so maybe something in this
area here
maybe even lower actually maybe we'll
just drop it down like this so the
majority of our image is focused
down in here now if i turn on the type
what i can do now is i could leave the
type centered like this
or i could go to the hot spot of my
composition which is this point right up
in here
and position that text right there
turn off my proportional grid
and there we have a professional looking
composition right it's not just your
typical type centered in in the middle
of the screen full size image we have
actually another rule of design here we
have negative space which is all this
white space up here and it's actually
something i wasn't going to talk about
today
but it this image by dropping the image
in the lower third of the screen we're
creating breathing room negative space
in the top of the screen
so that our type has plenty of room to
rest
to be seen to become a focal point
right now again these rules are here for
us to follow this doesn't mean that
everything you design everything you
create has to be exactly to these rules
it's just a great starting point because
once you know the rules there's a famous
saying once you know the principles of
design
now you can break those rules right it's
essentially like that so i could take
this text
you know over here to this
third most popular hotspot in this area
and i could turn off my proportional
grid here and again this looks pretty
nice as well maybe i'll undo that and
bring it back over here
and then also i could
position the image differently based on
the rule of thirds if i wanted to
so
let's move into this composition and oh
you know what let me back up one more
thing is i want to say is that this is a
1920 by 1080 composition but if i was to
change the size of the composite
composition to something like i don't
know 4k right
and back out now just disregard the
image and the text but if i turn back on
my proportional grid again it's
recognizing the size of this composition
and it's still creating that three by
three
box
grid over our composition so we're still
going to have the powerful rule of
thirds applied to this composition so it
doesn't matter what size your
composition is if you set up your
preferences here in grids and guides
to three by three
right here and right here and click ok
you'll be good to go let's go ahead and
undo that
okay let's jump into this other
composition here so
for this example i just wanted to show
you what i see a lot of motion designers
deal with which is okay i've got an
image or maybe this is a you know like a
3d render that happens back here for the
example here i'm just using a still
image but let's say this phone comes in
and spins around and it's doing some
things but we also have to have some
type on screen right so how do we make
this look
a little bit better
so the first thing we're going to do is
we are going to turn on our proportional
grid and we're going to align ourselves
our elements not ourselves we're going
to align our elements
with the rule of thirds and again it's
all a matter of taste you could come
over here you could could come over here
uh you could shrink it down i mean maybe
for this foam because it's so vertical
you're not going to want to go down here
or up in here
but
let's go ahead and let's just bring this
over here
something like that and i could scale it
down if i wanted to
um you know maybe it is a little bit
large so maybe something like that
um and then our text right so like
let's make our text
uh let's bring it
you know we could stick right here the
first thing i'm going to do is actually
i'm going to uh left align my text
so i bring this up here and i'm going to
left align it's always easier to read
text that is left aligned
and something else i'm going to do is
i'm going to use another design rule
which is contrast
okay
and essentially
contrast tells the viewers
where to
to look on your screen
where to look first and contrast can be
a difference in scale it could be a
difference in colors it could be a
difference in rotation
maybe you have a triangle and a square
right that's contrast so contrast is
just a difference in elements on your
screen and it tells us where to look
because of that so
for this example i'm going to use
contrast in two different ways i'm going
to use it in scale so i'm going to scale
down this text so we have a very large
image or 3d rotation that's happening
here and we have smaller text over here
right so we're creating contrast in our
screen versus having something really
large like this and everything's
competing on screen like where do we
look right we don't know where to look
because we're not using contrast but if
we
shrink this down and
i don't know maybe move it over in here
maybe actually kind of just bring it in
this area right here
that's already creating contrast maybe
we could take it down here
one other way to create contrast though
is as you can see right now i'm using
helvetica and i'm using a bold typeface
so
that's making the typeface
in essence more readable but what if we
were to make it a really light typeface
and i should probably select that type
first
there we go and we'll change it to
helvetica light so we're going
uh
several steps down
to
create a very light typeface
and let me turn off the sound over here
there we go uh so now we have even more
contrast right because before we were uh
bolded with this type so it's still
somewhat competing with this image and
this type
but by making it a very light typeface
it's creating even more contrast at this
point right
now i could go even smaller
and maybe bring it up in here now again
this is our our number one hotspot so my
attention
immediately is in here but because i'm
looking at this line as well
this is
drawing my attention to it
and i'm kind of trying to balance which
is another design rule trying to balance
with this instagram logo here and this
one so it makes the image a little bit
wider
but i'm just kind of paying attention to
the lines here
and
you know maybe we actually will bring
this down in here now a lot of times
what i like to do is turn off the
proportional grid at this point and when
i turn it off i can see things a little
clearer and i don't like this right off
the top i don't like this so what i'll
do now
is
kind of drag it around the image feels
very
heavy up in here and not so heavy down
here so let's bring it down to here and
then let's turn our proportional grid
back on
and
[Music]
maybe bring it over
you know something like this again it
doesn't have to be perfectly centered on
this point uh it could be
you know somewhere in here i know this
is the general area so again i'll turn
it back off
and
maybe bring it a little bit closer
i'm actually going to bring the design
in a little bit
maybe now take this out a little bit
like that
and that's looking pretty good now one
way i could make this even better
looking is instead of using just a
straight up black
typeface like i'm doing here
i could take my color dropper here
and i could select
a color
from my imagery right so maybe it's
purple that's not too bad
it's a little challenging to read but
what i could do is open up the color now
and just go to my brightness
maybe drop it down
a little bit
something like that
uh looks pretty okay i could take my
eyedropper again
and i could sample
you know i could go
let's see here
that's actually pretty nice right there
i like that
yeah not too bad
so
one more thing i want to show you here
on design so we've got a nice little
composition set up and we could always
you know tweak and adjust things
as we move through this it feels like
quite a bit of type to to read
maybe we need to use some spacing here
maybe something like that
actually you know what let me show you
another rule here with contrast
so we'll put a period there and we're
going to do now is we're going to take
our contrast
within our type we're going to take it
and make it contrasty so we're going to
go from light we're going to step up two
sizes so regular and then bold
to create our type at the top here
and i actually added one extra sentence
or period there
and now we have even more contrast right
look how nice that looks iphone 13 pro
max is bolded the type below it is light
looks really nice
we could actually take this type now
highlight it make it a little bit
smaller let's go down maybe 10.
um
maybe not quite so much maybe we'll go
maybe
40.
and again i'm going to take my arrow
tool my selection tool turn back on my
proportional grid
maybe slide it over a little bit
something like that
yeah it looks really nice okay one more
design rule i'm going to show you here
and actually it seems like i've gone
beyond three right i'm doing like four
actually five here
i'm gonna take some texture so i'm gonna
take this texture right here which if i
double click it and i open this up
it's just a black and white texture
chalk wall i've got a guy outside my
window blowing the leaves per usual
seems to be the story of my life here
and i lost my window so let's bring this
over hopefully you guys can hear that
noise
too loud
going to bring in my
texture because texture is so so
important
when it comes to
giving your compositions even more life
right even giving them more visual
interest i love texture so i'm gonna
drop it in here i'm gonna go to my
transfer modes and i'm gonna use
something like overlay
and boom immediately it becomes much
more it's very subtle back here right
and like let's say maybe i want to bump
up that texture just a little bit so i'm
gonna go to effect color correction
i'm gonna go to levels
and i'm going to
just bring in a little bit of contrast
there
and i don't know how much of this you
can actually see
uh in the image here
but uh it looks pretty nice i like it a
lot i've got actually a second texture i
can just try out just to see nope i like
that original one
so just adding in that texture
gives this composition more life right
it gives us more visual interest
things to look at it's
um versus just a solid background color
which is okay
uh
hi ollie my dog's in here now um it just
gives us more visual interest more
things so it gives us more depth within
our composition and it makes the more
makes the composition more pleasing to
the eye so
that is what i got for you guys today
um on uh three simple it's actually more
like five simple
methods for improving your design if you
were to implement these simple simple
things rule of thirds
contrast
texture and then the bonus ones were
negative space
and what was the other one
don't remember hierarchy and in text
there we go uh can make can be a game
changer for your designs
okay
that is what i wanted to teach you guys
today i'm going to see if you guys have
any questions for me
[Music]
and there's the guy blowing outside my
window again hang on just a second
uh when you realize that 2d isn't enough
and you started to use cinema 4d you
know so no i still um huge
i love 2d i love 2d i love two and a
half d is what i call it when you take
flat shapes and put them in 3d space
uh i love using that i use cinema 4d
very little
uh use it when i have to use it so like
the example i just showed you with the
phone i would have to probably create
that phone in cinema 4d and so i would
animate that the phone's spinning in and
things like that and then put use after
effects to put the screen within it
and after effects for everything else
but for the most part i'm strictly after
effects based there's so much you can do
with 2d 2 and a half d and 3d
within after effects
and i recommend everyone start with
after effects because at the end of the
day even if you're instead of a 4d
doing a lot of work in there you still
have to come back to after effects most
of the time to do color correction
compositing and things like that
um daniel
what is the smallest type size you
recommend ever using for 16x9 you know
it really depends on what you're trying
to do like i've used
um
gosh what was it like when i was doing
disclaimers
one time for like a toyota commercial
and i want to say we were using a six
point type for the disclaimer at the
very bottom of the screen
and you couldn't read it and it's like
that's doesn't seem like it's readable
to me but the agency was insistent on
that being the point size and i guess
they didn't care so it you know it
really just depends on on what you're
trying to show um one one thing to
consider is how long is the how long are
you showing the type on screen
uh if it's for several seconds
or five or ten seconds or even longer
you can get away with smaller type
because you have more time to kind of
focus in and read on that type
if it's a very quick shot
you know you want to be careful with how
small your type is because you want the
audience to be able to read whatever
that type is in that quick
flash
so i always shy away from larger type uh
smaller type is typically the way to go
it looks better
with your designs i see that a lot of
motion designers tend to use type that's
too large
because you feel like it needs to be
large and in charge on screen
uh for people to read but it really just
comes down to how long
does a viewer have to view that screen
and also
uh how important is it that they read
that type some type is just on screen
for
for as a design element and it's not
that important to read
whereas other type is super important to
read
uh anything on saber i love sabre i
think it's an awesome plug-in
i've used it since it came out um
using creating neon strokes and things
like that it's a lot of fun
uh anna thank you for sharing the tips
you're most welcome
are there any other 3d plugins for a
you'd recommend other than element 3d um
off the top of my head no i don't even
use element 3d i have it i've used it
for one project in my career and that's
it and that was because i had to use
create some very simple text very
quickly
and i think the other members of the
team were using element 3d
if that's why i used it
no but i mean there's so much you can do
with flat imagery inside of after
effects where you layer it back in z
space
to create
i guess i mean i still i can call it two
and a half d but it's like a flat 3d
that can look very
realistic and can trick your audience
into thinking that they're seeing
something that's truly three-dimensional
so that's kind of where i tend to go
i don't
you know if i'm building simple text
that's three-dimensional in after
effects i just use after effects i use
the cinema 4d render engine inside of
after effects i also use cinema 4d lite
which is built into after effects and it
launches the light version of cinema 4d
if you have the adobe
subscription you have cinema 4d lite
it's included with it and it's a
stripped-down version of cinema 4d that
you can do a whole lot of things with
with type and shapes and whatever so
that is typically where i go to because
it's built into after effects
what's the best codec for rendering uh
really just depends on where
where you're delivering my clients
typically always tell me what they need
it at
so that's who's telling me
what they need if i'm sending something
to broadcast
film based tv whatever i'm typically
going to use a prores
4444
or 422 hq
if it's going straight to web h264
but a high encode rate
jw is looking forward to style frame
challenge awesome yeah i'd love to have
as many of you sign up as you can
it's going to be awesome five days of
live teaching and q a
um what streaming tools do you use for
youtube i use ecamm live ecam live
it's mac based only
uh aaron one of my biggest hurdles is
managing cache space storing files and
optimize optimize my workspace so my
comps are rendering fast getting a new
macbook soon any thoughts for starting
fresh
uh yeah when you're starting a new
computer
typically i always use um
external drives for my um
media
and project files and i love the t5
drive this guy right here i don't know
if you guys can see that it's from
samsung
and i have i think two terabyte drives
these are two terabytes and they're
super fast because they use the uh the
lightning
on apple i don't know what to be called
on i guess is it usbc on the pc
uh super fast so i keep all my files
external i keep my applications on my
internal hard drive
and then
the biggest thing is that if you're
getting a new macbook get the fastest
cpu speed you can get
and get as much ram as you can get so i
typically recommend 128 gigs down to 64
gigs but you know so you can work with
32 gigs 16 gigs i don't recommend it
as much memory as you can
and the fastest cpu clock speed you can
get
all right my friends
that is all the questions i have for
today
again i do have a um
not this one not this one wrong wrong
link free 5 day challenge coming up
motion science dot tv slash challenge i
would love to see you guys there i'm get
really deep into style frame design
and how to do it i talk more in depth
about the different rules of design how
easy they actually are to apply as you
saw today they're easy the rule of
thirds is a game changer if you know
what it is and how to use it it
completely changes your compositions and
how they look
i go deeper into actually designing the
style frames and i show you my process
of what i do
and how i make it pretty easy to do so
that is all i've got for you today and
i'm going to wrap with this the best way
to get better at motion graphics is to
keep creating and practicing watch other
people's work learn from it and find
ways you can improve upon it
stay motivated experiment with new
techniques and above all else have fun
with your work because with enough
practice
you'll become a master of the craft and
produce stunning visuals that capture
people's attention
you have a very unique skill
that very few people possess
thanks for being here today
my name is cameron and this is motion
science